Benji did some crazy thing he went to a
pillow fight that we say an organized
pillow fight who put it on Benji I don't
know it's one of those Street feeder
things that they just do it's a it's a
pillow fight where in time she was in
Union Square which is down in the
village ma'am
it's called something like new free
space new mind space I don't remember
it's not they I don't know that they
made any money off of it I don't know
how many people show up for a pillow
fight was I thought it was just gonna be
a few people and I was worried I was
like no one's gonna show up but it was
hundreds of people there was a lot of
guys that really wanted to hurt people
it's fun I mean they were hitting you
really hard mosh pit that's what it was
like it started kind of innocent I mean
you could really get hurt in someone
good honestly yeah you know I mean I
mean some dude bashing you with a pillow
and people were acting crazy some guy
lit his pillow on fire I was crowd
surfing it was always at you who lit the
pillow yeah oh oh you were the crazy
various that's the pillow fight
[Applause]
that bench is getting it dude
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy to stop the tape Rizzo why did you
take your clothes off
well I thought we were gonna have a
countdown and in the middle that was
gonna like I had pre-cut my shirt so I
could rip it off like The Incredible
Hulk no but I just started and I just
thought it'd feel better and what
happens like you gotyou you exerted so
much energy you had to lay down about
ten seconds I really couldn't move like
my I guess I'm out of shape you're gonna
do it , he wouldn't do a couple I said
he had to take a pillow and lay down and
then this woman comes over and freaks
out Wow because she's like oh are you
alright sir you are right around and
then he whacks her in the head with a
pillow people are stepping on
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
beating
stupid event is that do you like having
a heart attack do it it got really bad
because then all these little kids
wouldn't stop hitting me and it was
really painful there's also some sort of
like I don't know why there's a sex and
media protest going on and you might
over there rejoin that - I don't know
how people pillows it you can't hit them
look no I joined like these these girls
dancing and rapping about sex and media
video what are they dancing about sex in
the media and you got up and answer them
that Jesus ban sermon how come they're
not acknowledging your baby meanwhile
Benji's not that bad a dancer he's doing
things but put a bandit Benjy cam on and
man he starts to perform